a leading uk medical school says that
the training for doctors in britain is
inherently racist
the university of bristol medical school
says urgent action needs to be taken to
examine why
teaching mainly focuses on how illnesses
affect white people
historically medical education was
designed and written by white
middle-class men
and so there is an inherent racism in
medicine that means it exists
to serve white patients above all others
we are teaching
students how to recognize a life or
death clinical sign
largely in white people and not
acknowledging these differences
may be dangerous bristol medical school
notes that doctors are
currently trained to be on the lookout
for patients turning blue
that criterion fails for non-white
patients the issue has been raised after
students complained that they were left
ill-prepared to treat patients from
ethnic minority backgrounds
now the uk medical school council says
it's putting plans in place to improve
the situation
is working with universities to
diversify curricula and improve
support for people dealing with racism
not everyone's persuaded though that
medical treatment can
suffer from bias
i've never read more nonsense in my life
i can understand the statement that
doctors need to have the skills needed
to treat ethnic minority patients better
but i'm not sure this is the same thing
as decolonizing the medical curriculum
i also thought the biggest effect on
health was poverty
hmm no good scientist would hold racism
as a viable theory medical education may
require
improvement in terms of approach to
racial characteristics
but i remain unpersuaded that a culture
of racism is present
we heard contrasting views on the issue
from former senior nurse rebecca butler
and bristol university medical student
orie odabi the issue at hand is the fact
that
whilst we do have a considerable number
of the populations
turning blue if they are diagnosed we
have
a very significant proportion of the
population
which will be increasing as we continue
with time
that won't manifest in that same way and
can't afford to be making mistakes
and if it can be rectified earlier in
medical education when we're given the
theory
that it is applicable to everyone as
well as white people but
black people and people of darker skin
colors that's great and that's something
we should be working towards so that our
medical education system is adequately
preparing all doctors across the country
for the diverse population that they're
meant to serve well that's just
ridiculous i mean
it's cyanosis and actually one of the
signs of hypoxia
is either the patient appears quite red
or they do go a gray
color round the mouth and on their
fingertips
and in a afro-caribbean person i was
always taught to look at the underside
of their palms
not at their fingertips because with a
dark skin coloration
you can't see the blue so easily but
they would also be breathless they would
also be perspiring
they would also have a raised pulse rate
it's not the only sign and
it's just ridiculous jumping on a racism
bandwagon over this
when it's a problem that doesn't exist
at all the fact that
patients of different colors and skin
types and different races
are erased from the patient picture of
health in traditional medical education
and one could argue yes that is
underpinned in racism because it erases
the fact that there are people
in this population who aren't white who
will not manifest with illness in the
same way and if that theory is
consistently
left out from the medical school
curriculums it will do a disservice to
not only doctors in training
but to the patients that they will
eventually go on to serve
the word it raises is what you need to
look at here nobody is erasing
anybody in the british health service if
you go to india
or nigeria or parts of sub-saharan
africa
all the medical schools there will teach
cyanosis
i was educated in india half my friends
are doctors
i've tweeted about this and asked them
about this over the course of the day
of course they learn about blues skin
coloration
um everybody i know talks about it
nobody is erased in the british health
service
you